from the Washington examiner George
Soros says DeSantis will beat Trump for
GOP nominations this is so funny so does
that does that just seal the deal for
everybody that DeSantis is not their guy
the you know it's like they're so
clearly putting their putting the extra
sandbags on the scale for DeSantis and
all the mega people are going to be like
you're totally trying to steal the
election before you know the election
even happens you're trying to like add
all this extra weight in favor are you
saying that this is an attempt to hurt
DeSantis I think this I think there's an
attempt to hurt Trump or no no this is
an attempt to hurt DeSantis yeah you're
right because George Soros yeah because
with the scientists they're scared of
him so they want them to think that they
are the ones that are supporting him so
that the conservatives won't support him
they'll turn away from him
it's like fainting yeah I think that
makes more sense yeah you think he's
gonna you think the Santa's even gonna
run
I think he will I think he will better
question who do you think is a is the
most viable option for President coming
up
I I who could run like are we talking
electability I hate that word yeah I'm
talking about someone that wants someone
obviously that's going some I don't know
what I think Haley for sure
but she is Pastor Prime look I I'm not
saying that if you Google it she's not
Don lemon's choice right Don Lemon Don
Lemon expert on women
now I I would think that DeSantis has
the likability and the policies that
he's like like everybody likes him other
than like the mega people I think he has
a real shot of winning well the Maga
people would like him if Trump endorsed
him exactly
people want Jimmy Dore for president
yeah Kanye's throwing his hat in the
ring Kanye door Kanye is actually yeah I
don't think he's I don't think he's like
announced or anything but I think he's
definitely a couple months ago but I'm
pretty sure he's gonna do it I have a
feeling he'll follow through you think
yeah yeah he's got nothing else no he's
got nothing else going on it's a big
deal you know running for president he's
been thinking about it for like eight
years too he's talking about it well he
almost ran before
whoa he did run like a cord underneath
my leg did you just pull the plug on the
no the Crazy Horse right here and
knocked it off all right I want to run
for VP this year what do you guys think
you know you used to be able to run with
somebody that's how it would go in the
early days of the United States is
whoever was second whoever got the
second most votes for president would be
VP that's how you had
um that's how you had Washington Adams
that's how you had Adams Jefferson that
makes sense too it does make sense you
know that's how the libertarian party
selects their VP candidates so they
select their presidential candidate and
then everybody in that wants to run for
VP runs for VP so they have two separate
elections to determine who's going to be
on the top of the ticket and then
whoever wants to run for the bottom of
the ticket runs as well
it was also that first Washington Adams
Administration that set the tone for the
VP having no power
really yeah yeah because like Hamilton
got in Washington's ear and basically
was saying that Adams was a monarchist
or something like that and so then
Washington was like really hesitant to
include Adams in any decision making and
Adams just kept going to the Senate
every day instead oh
okay so what
powers does the VP actually have other
than like breaking ties in Congress oh
sorry well it's not the border for sure
you know uh but you I don't think the VP
has any designated Powers the VP has
like stuff that the president would give
them to do right so like the VP always
has like some sort of project kind of
like the first lady you know someone
just sent me an AI deep fake of trump
complaining about Australia
how is it it's hilarious but I'm just
sitting here thinking like
we someone a friend of mine sent me 11
Labs AI stuff then we talk about on the
talk about it on the show and now
everyone's posting stuff like crazy
everywhere hmm like we're we're a month
out this election is gonna be it's gonna
be nuts yeah you think the centers are
going to win wild you're gonna have
full-throated endorsements from George
Soros talking about how Rhonda Sanders
is the greatest candidate of our of this
or any generation and then people are
going to believe it you're gonna get
Klaus Schwab endorsing Trump Hillary
Clinton endorsing DeSantis Bernie's
gonna come out in favor of Joe Biden
then what's gonna happen if that
happened already I Think Jesus is really
going to come back as a deep thick if we
have us nobody knows what Jesus sounds
like so yeah yeah
you know and of course that's the uh
that's the old joke but um the thing too
is what was I gonna say you go ahead I
don't know I was saying when you saw
frogs this morning and it's winter time
here so I said it was raining frog so
maybe we are at the end of times you saw
frogs raining down no they were running
across the road but I made the joke that
it's raining frogs maybe we're at the
end of times you know
you're not the first person to make that
statement and not even a joking matter
lots of people have have said that we're
in the end of days yeah people always
like to say that and now we have Revival
meetings in Kentucky so maybe we're
going to have something like that but if
you actually read it like the mark of
the beast you can't buy or trade unless
you bear the market now we got social
credit scores
it's the apocalypse which means the
Revelation or disclosure I mean talk
about the age of information being
released to the public this is the full
this is the age of disclosure there was
something here with the bear the bear
and the something else it basically
symbolize Russia and China when you look
at it and when the bear is a dragon or
something it's something like that it
was like the and then it has like
um it basically signified like a nuclear
war or something like that would that
would end all civilization if we have a
situation where it's just a ton of deep
fakes of everybody you know these
various endorsements or what have you
um how how is the public gonna stay
engaged in the election process don't
you think people are just going to start
tuning out entirely and just go with
their own Buy biases remember that dude
who got arrested because he posted a
meme that was voter misinformation or
something yeah he lost I think I mean
it's going to be Bonkers in 2024 when
people are putting out videos of Joe
Biden being like make sure you turn up
to your local fire department this time
and this date and then people are going
to be like hey that tricked me and I
couldn't vote and then
yeah look all dirty games will be played
all wild
totally wild and especially among the
left because these people these people
are willing to go to prison for this
stuff yeah well people on the right go
to prison for this stuff like you know
that happens too yep but the left
they're very much well because they're
True Believers yeah always beware the
True Believer yeah man it's gonna be
interesting DeSantis saying offensive
things and and it's like we were talking
about the beginning of the show they're
the videos that are going to work are
going to be ones that aren't
unbelievable it won't be Donald Trump
saying an end bomb or something it'll be
him saying something like you know I'm
I'm in favor of gun control I said it
before I'll say it again I'm gonna take
the guns as soon as I get an office but
I just won't say it while I'm running
and then people are going to be like and
he's going to lose support because
people will believe it and it's going to
be things targeting the right you know
you don't need you don't you don't need
to say anything May the left hate Trump
they already hate him yeah it's easy for
them to hate Trump that's the key of
meditation is not get triggered like
don't let stuff trigger you
um I don't know if assume it's all a
deep fake off the bat because sometimes
you yeah just assume it's all don't make
assumptions but just keep in mind that
it could be fake when you see anything
on there it's very difficult to navigate
reality when you can't tell what
actually is real and what's not
I mean I think that you know just
waiting things out is a always a good
plan like when things start coming out
you got to start just listening and
being like okay let's let this situation
calm down because what you're thinking
right now is probably not what's
actually happening except for the
chemical spill man that I was like you
know what Dan be the consequences
everyone get water filtration and air
filtration now look at this graphic I
don't know if it's real or not take care
of yourself like I'm not waiting for
government I'm not waiting for a
confirmation I don't even know if the
chemical spill really happened it's all
through the media that I've heard about
this but I'm not yeah I'm still going to
talk about it but Preppers have been
telling you this for a while so maybe
this is how they're making some money
off of it
it's like we were talking about before
where people were posting videos online
to make a fake event being like oh look
at this and it's a video from 2010 of a
military transport but they claim it
happened yesterday and then someone gets
a video of a cop running into a building
and they're like look
for all we know half the story is put up
by the media are just that mass hysteria
to trick us into believing these things
are happening when nothing's happening
well there certainly has been that I
mean remember the case of what was the
there was like a New York Times
journalist who was eventually found out
but it turned out he was just making
everything up yeah wasn't there a bill
of guy too Derek Bell is that
but why do why do you need to make up
fake stories when you have people like
George Santos out there that has a shady
pass that he was lying about well he was
just hanging out in his apartment and he
wanted to do work you work in a
newspaper you don't want to work you
want to make money so you just make it
up yeah that's what they do what's the
guy's name I don't want to start naming
Derricks from The New York Times
well he wouldn't work there now he
doesn't work there now what was his name
New York Times Faker really did he go to
did he get fined or go to prison or
anything why would he it's free speech
just to lie to the public yeah of course
lying is Free Speech Jason Blair not
Derek Bell I don't even know who that is
Val is the guy he's the critical race
theorist bad guy that's right I mean he
makes stuff up too I'm over here totally
fake news yeah it was Jason Blair what
did he do he uh he plagiarized and made
stuff up and was writing for the New
York Times recently he resigned in 2003.
oh okay that was a long time yeah it was
a long time ago but there was that guy
from probably still happening I think it
was build or whatever that German
newspaper and he was just fabricating
news he get a bunch of awards or
something
it's amazing in it yeah but now they've
evolved to making up having machines do
it for you and you don't know that it's
them I think it's the idea you don't
want to be the next Jason Blair what's
up Jason yeah thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time